hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chincenses.com
so as usual i'm here to make some
technical analysis and as you know i
have now more time
so today i want to try something new i
want to make a double update guys on
gamestop and amc in the same video so
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so let's start with amc so
yesterday was actually quite a bloody
day for
both stocks so i'm gonna as usual
analyze every information that i get
from the market i'm gonna show you
what technique or indicator i use to
process
this information and how i build up my
scenarios and choose my preferred one
i'm gonna
remind you guys what i told you
yesterday for both amc and gamestop and
we're gonna analyze what happened
and what might happen next so the first
thing
on amc i told you guys that uh on the
short term we had
this strong support on the 50 period
moving average on the hourly time frame
and yesterday this got broken all right
guys
it it's totally fine i mean you know on
the short term
basically we had you know kind of
different signals
uh going to different directions so the
first signal we had is that we were
trading above this 50 moving average
but the other signal that we had and
that i showed you guys as well yesterday
was this bearish exaggerated divergence
so on the hourly time frame guys all
right the last time i had one on the 30
minutes time frame
here so let me first show you what is an
exaggerated bearish divergence
quickly so it's this one okay and it's
very different from
a bull flag so here in the situation the
market is actually failing to make a new
high
with the momentum indicator for example
the macd going lower
so it's exactly what we're having here
the market is failing to make a new high
it's trying to make a new high it's
actually making a flat
but the momentum indicator is going
lower and this is very different from a
bull flag
because in a bull flag actually the
market is
going lower it's consolidating so if you
had something like this guys
you know it's funny but actually if nmc
traded lower
two days ago it would have been more
bullish
than amc going at 64 and failing to make
a new high because
this makes it a divergence and here for
example you can see
that the magnet is going lower you know
from here to here
and the market is going lower as well
this is what we call a consolidation
period this is a bull flag right both
sides can be done with flat zigzags or
triangles
but each time here you have lower highs
with the magnetic going lower
in the kind of divergence in the
situation of a divergence
you don't have this lower highs if we
had
this once again guys this would have
been more bullish
but we had this which is a bearish
exaggerated divergence
which was what for me put some pressure
on the price action basically
the bears were more confident yesterday
and they made their pawns because amc
closed on the day
i think six percent down but yes you
know once again
let me remind you the big picture so let
me just finish here
on this bearish so hidden divergence
that got its
impact on the price action and my
preferred scenario was we go right away
here
but you know i had an alternative
scenario with quite a high probability
as well
that is actually the one that is playing
out and that is you know amc just going
lower
so for me we could go as low as 48
as i told you and my scenario that is
here one two
would still remain intact so to know
that guys i just
you know look at the fibs and as long as
we are
above the 61.8 percent we are fine we
could go as low as
78.6 percent and it still could be a
one-two but
most of the one two we having in the
third wave usually the second wave
doesn't go below the 61.8 percent
retracement level
so this is for me the level above which
everything is totally fine
so yeah once again we kind of have the
feeling that yesterday the birds were in
control
but guys let me remind you that we are
trading at 55
that we are coming from you know levels
around five to ten
few months ago and trust me that you
know the best remember this because
they lost a lot of money during this
whole move up
so the bears are here wounded they're
actually deeply wounded
and you know when the price action is
just retracing like this
it's actually good we're gonna go to
take some
more liquidity sitting at this levels
there are a lot of people that are just
waiting to buy the deep on amc
and if they do maybe it would be the
time you know to just
win one more battle and the bulls could
be in control again
so what i mean is that on the long term
bulls are totally in control
this is what actually i see from my
technical analysis
and here once again this exaggerated
various divergence on the hourly
timeframe i think
would still have some impact maybe on
tomorrow's
like on tuesday's training session so we
might go to the 48 level
this wouldn't be that surprising for me
now my scenario is here one two three
four five
same abc so i told you guys either my
abc is a small abc here
and this is a one two so this was like
this
or uh here we fail to actually go higher
right away
and it's just a bit an abc that is just
lasting a bit
longer but it's still an abc and once
again the c wave could go like even here
to 48
it would be totally fine for me so i
don't have here a very precise
scenario either we bounce back right
away but
my preference now is actually we go a
bit lower here we take some fresh
liquidity
and we just reload guys because this
liquidity is the weapons that
you know bulls you guys the the apes are
using against
the hedge funds the market makers that
are actually
shorting uh this stock and sometimes
it's good to go at
a bit lower level to get this fresh
liquidity and to use it against the best
so once again this is looking totally
fine for me
okay now i want to talk about gamestop
so
here what do we have guys so once again
let me remind you what i said yesterday
so in my yesterday's video guys i told
you that i was here
spotting you know kind of
exaggerated bullish divergence so it was
actually the opposite
of what i was seeing on amc so it's the
same one guys it's
this one but once again you know this
exaggerated divergence they are a bit
weaker than the
normal divergences because the price
action is actually not making a new low
so here let me remind you what it was
so i was seeing here the market making
you know not able to make a new low
with the macd going higher so this for
me was looking bullish
and i was actually you know kind of
seeing this
wedge pattern from in here and i wanted
to see a breakout on the upside
unfortunately gamestop lost how much six
percent guys you know it's not
big moves like seriously do those kind
of moves guys it's like you know
let me show you just quickly the
volatility guys of gamestop
all right so this is the option open
interest i have here all the information
about the options
and you can see that for example on the
500 strike for example in the july
maturity the velocity is at 240
guys all right so in terms of daily move
you just divide this by 16
and it's like around 15 percent of daily
move guys so one
game stop is moving by six percent and
especially
look at the volumes guys the volumes are
you know the weaker volume we had
for a very long time you know i only
like five million shares traded
yesterday
you can see it's here guys it's very low
volume we almost never have
so small volumes especially on the you
know apparently strong bearish day
guys this was you know this is a strong
bearish day okay
we can see more we find i mean if this
is the best they can do
it's fine it's totally fine and guys i
had this exaggerated bearish divergence
now it's not exaggerated it's
you know let me get rid of that so i'm
gonna show you my new scenario
but right now guys the market is making
new lows
lower lows that's very clear to me
lower lows and look at the macd so we
don't have it on the first time frame
but look at the hourly timeframe
so here market still making lower lows
and the macd
here guys the macd making
higher lows so this is a
bullish regular divergence so now we
have it so what does it mean it means
that yesterday was
a day won by the best but guys the
victory is
very small very tiny and we can
read it in the momentum because even if
they made a new low
they made it with a higher momentum so
that's why the new is actually not deep
at all
and you know you can see it in the
volumes you can see in the daily
performance six percent
compared to 14 of average daily move
when you look at the option market and
you can see it in the momentum indicator
so for me once again uh same answer here
it doesn't change anything to what i was
saying guys before
it would just maybe take a little bit
more time so let's analyze
where we actually got a reaction here so
we got the reaction around the 200 level
and it's funny guys to actually notice
that
you know i've always told you when you
have a breakout the breakout is usually
retested you know 90
of the time so here we go guys this is
the breakout level that has just been
retested yesterday and i can tell you
that there were a lot of people
waiting here to buy and i'm not sure
they bought yesterday i think they did
look i wanted to show you something very
interesting if you go on a five minutes
time frame
on a five minute time frame look at the
volume so this is yesterday
okay so yesterday started here
and you can see that the higher volume
of the day
was here so basically when we went
through the 200 level why
interesting because both you're having a
lot of stop losses
a lot of maybe bullish investors that
said okay i'm gonna buy some shares at
215 but i'm gonna stop my position if
gamestop
trades below 200 maybe but if you have
this
high volume here when we go strongly
down as you can see
basically gamestop was you know going
lower lower lower lower
and then suddenly bam we have this
massive
quantity of shares that is sold at the
200 level probably
it was when we started to trade just
below the 200
level and we still didn't go lower
the five minutes candle that is coming
just
right after the the one that broke the
200 level
is actually very bullish what does it
mean it means that we have a lot of bias
here and even
if you have this strong volume that is
trying to go through the level
the buying power is still strong enough
to right away make it bounce back so
okay
it went then after below this and we
closed slightly below this but basically
this is just a consolidation area around
the 200 level so this is once again
showing me
that even in weekdays like yesterday low
volumes
and the buying power is actually here
guys is actually here and
that's why the price action actually
stayed that high
i'm sorry six percent move down is very
small for a stock like gamestop
especially
when we having you know this kind of
sentiment that is shifting you know
we've been consolidating here for
what one week and we broke you know the
level the 215 level roughly 210
level we broke it but we broke it with a
very
small intensity actually we didn't go
that low
and the price action was actually to me
showing
quite bullish signs here so let me
remind you now
my scenario guys so like i said we have
now here
a clear bullish regular divergence guys
on the hourly time frame we don't have
it on the flowers
so we have it on the hourly time frame
so this means that probably
we're gonna have some bullishness coming
back tomorrow
like on tuesday and wednesday session in
terms of levels
let's have a look at where we are
correcting so we broke the 61.8
okay 215 level got definitely broken
on the daily time frame uh on the first
time frame as well so once again i don't
like this area
this is something i need to tell you
guys i don't like this area everything
between 78.6 and 61.8
is an area that to me you know where
bears are actually you know
more in control that's why they manage
here to break the 210
level but once again the boos flex their
muscles here definitely and we can see
some bullish momentum coming back here
with the macd
trading higher so i don't really like to
be in this area
i don't think we're gonna stay here very
long so my preferred scenario is
simple guys is that we bounce back right
away and we do one two three four five
my alternative scenario is that here we
don't only correct to the 200 level
but the next support level is here guys
the top of wave one if you want to find
the support and resistance levels you
know after a strong move up like this
let me remind you guys you know we're
here talking about six percent move down
all right
but we took 150 percent
you know there was 150 percent move up
guys
the past month so once again this is
totally normal to consolidate and
it's fine for me if you want to find the
support level after the strong move up
you just
check at the highs and the lows created
by
the preceding elliot wave counting that
we we're having here
so here the top of the first wave is 190
so this is our next support level so
this is my alternative scenario either
we bounce back right away
or we go slightly lower but guys this
would still be
a bullish regular divergence i'm sure of
this
and we would still do the one two three
four five that is coming later
so basically my longer term scenario is
totally unchanged we
are bullish here let me have a look
quickly at the option market data guys
so here guys same thing so we were at
215
so we had 1 billion usd in synthetic
short
right now we are 200 so we're having 800
million guys this
option distribution is still looking
very bullish to me
same for imc guys there is nothing very
new
here today for amc you can see that
we're having 10 percent of synthetic
short interest
uh the 145 strike is keeping growing so
same on gamestop guys that hundred
strike is like you know the one that is
consuming like the more
exposure here on this option market and
the last thing i wanted to
show you is uh when you try to
understand what created this move down
yesterday on gap stop because you know
all the broad market like the s p 500
the nasdaq they rebounded actually and
they made
some strong moves up so you're wondering
why gamestop and amc went down so you
just i
you know i usually go in yeah finance
it's quite good website to find
the news and i was expecting to find a
lot of bearish news but guys the first
thing i find
is actually this article gamestop
flanders but long-term catalysts remain
intact so low volume no conviction all
right i agree with that
not a lot of shares trading yesterday
and you know
actually gamestop is now entering in a
lot of etfs you know a lot of like asset
managers they want to
use the fact that a lot of investors are
attracted to stock like gamestop and
they just put it in the etf
in the etf they actually actively manage
so what
is it creating it's actually creating
some more buddhist momentum once again
because they when they buy the etf or
any investor buys the atf they need to
replicate
their etf strategy on the market by
buying some gift stop shares
so this is actually bullish and this is
coming on the bearish day so
interesting this is another divergence
case and the biggest divergence i find
in the news
is actually you know the one that i have
here so retail investors stock buying
boom of 2021
is just getting started goldman sachs
interesting interesting and it's
actually funny to see
so they basically explain you know that
people they invest more and more
in the equity market they're basically
saying here
additional any signs of a sustained
increase in inflation would favor
equities over born of cash
so the money is here because we printed
a lot of money you know to tackle the
coffee crisis
and this money is not going to the bond
market because if the inflation is
starting to grow
you know you're better off having some
return coming from the equity market
than some very uh close to zero interest
rates that you could have by investing
on the bond market so this is one of the
reasons with this uh you know inflation
that is now you know growing we can feel
it because of all the money that has
been flooded into the economy
so this makes sense but the investors
are are very bullish and they invest in
the equity market
and yes it's funny to see you can go and
check my videos i posted
i think like three or four months ago
when i was telling you that
nasdaq and the s p 500 are gonna enter
the biggest bubble
this article is basically saying the
same thing and you know they
say it like you know three or four
months after me
because probably they have more data but
i was already seeing this
in my technical analysis when the s p
500 broke the 3
800 level and the nasdaq broke the 12
000 level
so actually there were already some
early signs that all this money that is
flooded into the economy will go to the
stock market and will create a bubble
so i think those bubbles they will keep
happening that's why i'm
so bullish on gamestop and amc goldman
sachs is as well and trust me that if
there is
200 million shares trading every day on
amc it's not only the apes community you
know
buying and selling you know there are
more people more investors involved in
this trade
and goldman sachs is i think one of them
because they know that this is a way to
make some quick cash
so they are in the trade i'm not gonna
be always hundred percent right uh for
those who are following my channel for
some time you know that
most of the time i'm right you know like
we can say eighty percent of the time
but i remind you guys that
trading is about probabilities and
expected gains
so you know if your risk reward is just
high enough you can be wrong some of the
times
and here yesterday we had a british day
but we're gonna have some
more bullishness coming back in the game
so that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys